[Music]
delicious chip butty secret of a good
chip butty is in the potato now these
are désirée potatoes one of my first
ever jobs was working in a chip shop
nice to put sacks and sacks of potatoes
into the rumbler which will send the
potato peeler all day long today I'm
gonna do something a bit healthier for
my oven chips with a twist simply peel
slice and blanch for 3 to 4 minutes
drain season and cover well with paprika
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes simple as that
next up easy fish fingers this is
Pollock a really nice firm delicious
fish got the fish and finger size
patterns of fish put them onto your
plate and just lightly salt them you can
do that literally 20 minutes 30 minutes
before you start cooking the fish it
firms the fish up beautifully and they
allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour and then just
rolling to get rid of those little sharp
corners because then it stops those
corners almost burning in the pan in
your egg wash and really coat them
wonderful and then this is dill goes
brilliant over the fish and run the deal
through my breadcrumbs that makes it
more aromatic
laven onto your breadcrumbs nothing
wrong with the chip butty nothing wrong
with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side all the fish
fingers to be nice and crispy get a
really nice color on them first and then
we'll flip them over and finish them
with butter bring the heat up into the
pan a nice little normal butter now work
wonders with the breadcrumbs in the deal
nice and carefully take them out and
look you smell incredible say nice and
crispy now to assemble my chip butty
starting with buttered big crusty bread
[Music]
it's nice and wet mop up that amazing
flavor on slice in half
never slice in an angle my mouth is
salivating beautiful on weather ship but
II one thing missing and it signifies
that I've never forgotten the joy I've
come for food but my god that makes me
feel like a nine-year-old excuse me for
a moment we want to stuff my face
[Applause]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip butty so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing cooking is about
being adventurous and having the
confidence to go off piste and being a
little bit more daring so when you start
combining peanuts chili flakes and this
amazing fish red mullet trust me you in
for an amazing treat we're gonna make a
really nice light sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half and those seeds inside are very
powerful
incredibly hot but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic slice the garlic
nice and thin so it helps the puree
the chilies in the pesto more garlic in
such a salt and it will touch of sugar
in and then start grinding push down
first
the salt and the sugar really helps the
puree the chilli and the garlic fish
sauce always a base to a chilli sauce
two tablespoons in and a touch of rice
wine vinegar fish sauce gives it the
saltiness the vinegar gives it a nice
acidic wake up three tablespoons of
olive oil nice mix that up
beautiful okay the colors incredible now
spring onions I want the texture and the
crunch spring onions in the coriander
slice it once in fresh lime and that
goes brilliantly with a red mullet just
really wakes up the chilli the garlic
and reminds the sauce that was serving
tree fish and their taste
[Music]
well it's delicious look at that
beautiful the longer that chili sauce
sits there the better it gets
now the penis and chilli that's gonna
coat the top the red mullet peanuts in
salt in it helps the really grind the
peanuts down some people dried chili
flakes create a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of coriander mix the kinder
in to the peanuts and look I like them
quite textured I don't want them too
small as a powder otherwise they'll burn
but crushed lightly to coat the fish
with the chili and peanut seasoning in a
separate bowl beat two eggs along with a
splash of fish sauce
take your Philip lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts and then
end and make sure you push that down
cover that red mullet Oh beautiful now
make sure that pan is really nice and
piping hot if you put the fish in and
the pans cold all those wonderful
peanuts and chili just is gonna slide
off the fish so we need to sear it in
and get it nice and crisp in and lay
away from me beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot hit your ball and just place a
little teaspoon of olive oil around the
outside so it starts to heat up as it
hits the center and it really helps to
say so much more in control and turn
nice and gently they want that nice sort
of toasted sauteed crispness which it
adds a really lovely flavour tilt the
pan and just place the top of the red
mullet without really nice placing hot
olive oil you've got that really nice
roasted crunch and it goes brilliantly
without soft sweetness of that fish
inside guess off and just leave them
sitting in there and finish with lime
and just go over each one now you take
the mouse in the source touch on the
bottom in the turn of each fish now to
round that off serving some fragrant
rice study broccoli amazing and there
you have a delicious peanut encrusted
red mullet with a wonderful sweet chili
sauce cooking with chilies isn't all
about blow your head off heat this dish
uses the exciting taste of a chili but
has a deliciously elegant and subtle
flavor you know that feeling when you
really want a particular dish and
nothing else will do that's comfort food
multimap comforting lunch has to be fish
with peas I've loved it ever since I was
a kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks my
optimum fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger
to go with it Chile minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm the secret is to season
the fish
salt and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and they'll keep it official
really nice and firm put it in the
fridge for around 10 minutes to the
seasoning work it's magic that the
batter as always when making any batter
always sieve the flour or a bit of heat
in the batter so a nice teaspoon of
cayenne pepper season the flour salt and
pepper and then 2 teaspoons of baking
powder
this almost lightens the lobe of the
batter now ginger beer
it gives that batter this sort of unique
spicy individual flavor is delicious for
the fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic baseball oil gives it a nice
Sheen give that a good mix you really
want to almost like the consistency of
double cream to thin and the batter runs
off especially when it hits the fryer
too thick and it actually prevents the
fish from getting cooked so you're gonna
go into that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
is magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish was gone slightly firmer
perfect for frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper Pat's
that nice and dry into your hands see
I'm gonna excess flour the flour stops
the batter from running off the fish I'm
just gonna check to see them light all's
ready I burned a little touch of batter
in the fryer you see it bubbling
straight to the very top that tells you
that the oil is ready never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if it all
starts to get too hot first thing you do
turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now in and lay away and just gently chop
it in twist your pan that stops it from
sticking at the bottom oil should be
gently sort of bubbling away but notice
as we're frying the fish there's no
spitting of any water from the fish fry
the fish for three to five minutes
gently turning halfway through once the
batter is golden and crisp it's ready
they look stunning so these big crispy
pillows of beautifully textured pot
leave the fish to rest on a kitchen
towel to blot excess oil meanwhile it's
quick and easy chilly minted mushy peas
now the mushy peas a little teaspoon of
olive oil a nice knob of butter into the
pan shut up finely chopped that adds a
bit of sweetness to the peas slots into
the pan chew these are delicious when
you eat these and they're slightly spicy
they're even better garlic in the peas
sweat off the chili the garlic on the
schlotz before the peas join those
spices simply blanch in salted boiling
water infused with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks on all and then put
your frozen peas in now what's the piece
I've got a nice and soft drain them now
take off the stalks and then add the
peas to the shallows
I love that sound mix all that chilli
and garlic in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious onto your board
crush now you cannot beat crushed
delicious please yeah those peas
incredible top with chopped mint chili
minted mushy peas so simple and perfect
with easy ginger beer battered fish then
I spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
you're going to do it
do it properly
[Music]
my spicy twist is proved you can update
a comforting classic leather sole for me
one of the most flavorsome flatfish
twice as much flavor as the dover salt
and more importantly half the price skin
side down skin just nip at the end grab
it like this sort of almost pulling hair
and let the knife do the work season
dill dill and fish go brilliantly
because it's got that really nice sort
of fennel flavor that sort of aniseed
flavor and just roll almost like a
sausage please
carrots spring onions garlic it's a very
delicate dainty fish this so we don't
want to overpower the garlic and then
something just sort of wake them up a
little bit
thyme rosemary the time goes brillier
the leeks and the rotation goes
fantastic with the carrots baking paper
if I have to put them on my board by
that then they gonna curl up so I turn
the paper almost inside out add veg
we're looking for a bed like a nest of
vegetables
season and then just drizzle generously
with olive wolf
it looks delicious now is they even
cooked
taking piece of paper that goes over the
top wrap if you get the top right hand
corner then you just fold that over and
then over again fold and push I just
follow it round fold and push you've
left almost like a little snout white
wine what the wine does as that salt is
steaming there it makes a really nice
aroma with the vegetable the olive oil
and keeps everything really nice and
light and fruity seal pen on there and
push down
and look just seals the paper hot oven
20 minutes
and this is the bit of magic in and just
look and look at that absolutely
delicious and a perfume of the herbs
extraordinary salt crusted sea bream
served with braised leeks and hazelnuts
[Applause]
first job is that salt crust this dish
looks intimidating but it is actually
very straightforward and very easy make
sure all the guts are out and the fish
is clean the most important thing is
always leaving the skin and the scales
on that skin protects the actual flesh
would become a salty give the fish a
really nice seasoning inside even though
we're putting a salt crust on the
outside it's still very important to
season the middle fennel seeds goes
brilliantly well with fish and then
slice the lemon nice large thick slices
the zest and the lemon bakes inside the
fish fall over the fish and just squeeze
the juice now for the salt about a
hundred fifty ml to two hundred mil of
water what you're trying to do now is
bring the salt together and you want to
sort of end up with ball of salt that
looks almost like snow you'll need about
two kilos of salt for this and it
doesn't need to be the fancy stuff even
though you're using a lot of it it won't
make the fish salty instead the crust
forms are killed that retains moisture
basically a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down lay the fish on top of
the salt get your salt and just start
back in you can salt crust almost any
fish from sea bass to salmon or flatfish
like Sol but it's not great with oily
fish now it looks like a ridiculous
amount of salt but it's really important
to cover all the fish
because we want that nice shell and the
minute salt hits the oven this sort of
tightens up and forms this large crust
that goes in at 180 degrees for 25 to 30
minutes whilst the fish cooks is on to
my beautiful braised leeks splash of
olive oil leak is a very sort of firm
robust vegetable so it can take a really
nice sear
well most exciting about these leeks
Haylie go goose week with a sea bream
but braised leeks coloured properly with
a lot of flavor on there tastes
absolutely delicious take a couple of
cloves of garlic and just crush them in
with the leeks some fresh thyme get some
butter in there raising them in butter
and white wine gives me the most amazing
flavor brazing is a Chevy term for
searing at a high temperature then
cooking with a bit of liquid bringing
that up to the boil
and then the rest of the butter now as
the white wine reduces down the flavour
the leeks intensifying they'd Lai's turn
it down just leave that little gap there
if we totally covered it then again
they'd all that conversation from
underneath the lid they will just make
the leeks watery the leeks will take
about 12 minutes to cook so now for the
garnish roasted hazelnuts
they'll be roast in the oven very
brittle very firm so get an insight
pester mortar for the seasoning and just
crush your nuts don't over pan them I
just want this nice sort of rustic
chopped toasted hazelnuts now get your
knife you want that going through with
ease and turn off the gas I absolutely
adore them like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy now baste the
leeks with a remaining butter spread
your flat leaf parsley over generously
and then just sprinkle the toasted
hazelnuts the combination of that
earthiness from the leeks the roasted
flavored from the hazelnuts that is a
stunning way of eating leeks and after
the fish
look now just gently tap top and it
starts falling away you can just see
that beautiful shine carefully lifts off
so now peel that skin look juicy and
succulent that sea bream is stays
incredibly moist the other great thing
about cooking whole fish like this it
makes it so easy to fill it take your
spoon run that down through the top the
fish should just slide off
yeah now just push back that lovely
Philip and look that is cook goofy and
that's what keeps them coming back for
more and more and more when you have
friends over you want to keep lunch
relaxed lay back but impressive and a
salt crust brain with beautiful braised
leeks is just that